[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben der bug und koch kanal
lila kuchen hat eine wundervolle
kooperation ins leben gerufen und zwar
geht es hierbei um das thema halloween
gerade in diesem moment gehen auf ihrem
kanal und außerdem noch auf dem kanal
becking lauf und auf dem kanal esslust
wundervolle halloween videos online und
auf meinem kanal gibt super gruselige
halloween pudding geister ich habe eine
leckere dessert creme hergestellt mit
sahne und folglich kuvertüre und getoppt
wird das ganze mit gruseligen
sahnehäubchen
für zwei bis drei desserts benötigen wir
400 gramm schlagsahne 200 gramm förmlich
kuvertüre zwei packungen sahnesteif
außerdem noch ein plätzchen oder andere
kekse die ihr gerne mögt und für die
deko nochmal 200 gramm schlagsahne eine
packung sahne steif und für die augen
schokostreusel oder zuckerperlen zuerst
nehme ich mir 400 gramm schlagsahne
erhitze sie in einem kochtopf und gebe
sie in eine schüssel
so kommt jetzt die klein gehackte
vollmilch kuvertüre das ganze wird dann
einmal abgedeckt und fünf minuten stehen
gelassen
seit schmilzt die förmlich kuvertüre in
der sahne und jetzt bringen wir das
ganze vorsichtig mit einem schneebesen
um bald alles schön zu einer glatten
masse verrührt wurde lassen wir das
ganze komplett auskühlen und ich gebe
das für 30 minuten ins gefrierfach
in der zwischenzeit geben wir 200 gramm
schlagsahne und eine packung sahnesteif
in einen behälter und schlagen das ganze
steif
statt eine packung sahnesteif könnt ihr
hier auch zwei teelöffel sonderfahrt
benutzen
[Musik]
die steif geschlagene sahne geben wir
jetzt bis zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank und in der zwischenzeit bis
auch die ghanaer schon abgekühlt dort
geben wir jetzt auch noch mal das seiner
fahrt mit hinein und rühren das ganze
steif
sobald dann die ganz steif geschlagen
wurde erhaltet ihr so eine leckere
dessert creme und die könnt ihr dann
sofort in gläser abfüllen
mit hilfe meines spritzbeutel es gebe
ich jetzt die dessert creme auf den
boden gebe darüber einen einer plätzchen
und schichte dann so weiter bis das glas
voll ist
[Musik]
die eier plätzchen werden nach ein paar
stunden durch die feuchtigkeit der creme
weich und man kann es super schön
auslöffeln jetzt dekorieren mir aber
noch die pudding geister und zwar gebe
ich jetzt die steif geschlagene sahne
tütchen weise auf die creme
[Musik]
das gesicht gebe ich jetzt noch
schokostreusel auf die sahne
ich habe mir zu hilfe ein zahnstocher
genommen so beschädigt ihr auch die
sahne nicht und alles sieht schick aus
[Musik]
falls ihr euch auch traut die gruseligen
geist danach zu machen dann guckt euch
gerne mal in der infobox um da habe ich
alle zutaten aufgelistet und übrigens
auch die anderen kanäle die mitmachen
schaut doch gerne mal vorbei und lasst
ihn auch ein abo da und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal auf die keys kitchen
[Musik]